In the Gaza Strip, a funeral procession was held for two Hamas militants...
...that were killed by Israeli tank fire.
In Russia, members of the punk group Pussy Riot...
...protest mistreatment such as beatings, torture, and slave labor in penitentiaries.
In Japan, after undergoing an investigation,...
...a Tokyo medical school apologizes for systematically altering test scores...
...in entrance exams to prevent women from becoming doctors.
In Germany, a mother and her partner were sentenced to 12 years in prison...
...after being convicted of raping the woman's young son...
...and selling him for sex on the internet.
Finally from the U.S., singer Demi Lovato checked out of the hospital...
...after being admitted for an overdose on July 24.
She will now seek rehab.